so you have the margaritas for the
adults but if you're looking for
something sweet for the entire family
how about a paleta jay park is here from
the paleta bar to tell us about what's a
traditional mexican treat and now it's
being uh mixed with some asian flair so
it becomes a very international treat
tell us about how poleta bar works so
paletta is the handmade mexican popsicle
and we make everything fresh in the
house and so best thing about our paleta
is
you choose your palette and pick in like
a dip into the different chocolates so
you got option with the different
chocolate white dark milk chocolate and
you got another option with the topping
um and also with the fresh fruit right
so you have a selection here you have i
believe these are fruity pebbles yes
taken uh like oreos oreo yeah and the
this is the most popular one is the
graham cracker and we got some like a
tahin chamoy for like more for a water
base okay that's a spicier kind yes
right yeah okay so tell us how we're
gonna do it all right so we got the uh
strawberry one okay
so what we're gonna do is a dip into the
milk chocolate all right top dip and i'm
gonna put in the topping you guys have
been open for about a year you're on
spring mountain right yeah okay spring
mountain in valley view in that area
yeah in the shanghai plaza okay that's
great and you're doing great because he
opened up i guess toward the end of the
pandemic so things started warming up
and now you're really busy yeah that's
great all right let's dip it in
chocolate all right so what we're going
to do dip it in
go up
and i'm going to drizzle a little bit
here
i'm going to go here
and i'm going to go free that's fruity
pebbles all the way so it's going to
look great and you have fresh fruit as
well do you add the fresh fruit
afterwards yes afterwards okay what i'm
going to do is i'm going to put some
little bit fruit
and mangoes are great so i'm gonna put
some mango on top oh nice yeah
and they're really beautiful you have an
entire display here i don't know if we
can get a shot of that as well in these
boxes these are gorgeous they're really
beautiful on top really tasty
and now like what i'm gonna do like you
know i'm gonna put some little drizzled
chocolate on top so okay
so that's nice okay i'm gonna put some
more
so this is how we come up very nice
la paletta bar it's located on spring
mountain you're about to open up a
second location yes so slowly we working
on it so it's going to be in henderson
that's fantastic congratulations on all
your success too thank you i'm glad it's
going so well and these look fantastic
i'm going to try one uh we're probably
going to take off here in a few seconds
but see how
like
if i could possibly work for you yeah
now how do these not melt when i'm
putting these in here
oh so it would kind of put it in the
warm yeah
you don't want it boiling hot obviously
we're gonna do some graham cracker per
your recommendation perfect all right
and then we throw some fruit on yeah
wonderful so just a price point what are
uh so what can people expect when
they're so it's gonna be ranging from
the uh five to uh ten dollars okay so it
kind of depends on it's more optional
yeah so like they can go from like you
know uh from plane all the way to like
you know have a you know chocolate
topping and a fruit yeah that's very
reasonable and they're delicious on top
of everything else i'm gonna enjoy mine
rocky you take it from here
um i i prefer
your friend to make mine okay
just fyi i don't blame you